meanwhile what the texans will do after
the season is hire a general manager and
then hire a coach that's the right way
to do it don't do it backward don't hire
the coach and then hire the gm until
then
executive vp of football operations jack
easterby despite a fairly thin football
resume
and and i'm being kind despite a
virtually non-existent football resume
as a football a football proposition
right that's it let's you know character
coach that's not running a football
organization chaplain obviously that's
not running a football organization
there's that item on his resume from
2004 where it used to say
he was an assistant to the director of
football operations in jacksonville and
then it was changed
to say he assisted
he helped
with the football operations department
it was an internship while he was in
college
right so that that that's it
that's that's the football credential
that allows him to be the interim
general manager of the houston texans
the interim i was stunned by that i i
i knew he was going to emerge from this
thing with more power and influence but
i never would have dreamed that they'd
make a guy with a a thinner football
resume than you chris from the
standpoint of front office and personnel
and coaching right the interim general
manager of the team i mean you at least
worked in football for the patriots for
a year and a half that's a hell of a lot
more experience than jack easterby's
gotten as an actual football
guy yeah right character coach that's
not it that's not teaching you how to
run the salary cap that's not teaching
you how to properly do trades that's not
teaching how to evaluate you know
there's a lot of work being done but the
next year's draft next year's free
agency a lot of stuff that the gm's in
charge of right i'm stunned by that i'd
rather see romeo cornell interim gm i
mean if it was good enough for the coach
the last time bill o'brien to be the gm
as well why not make the interim coach
the interim gm so anyway i haven't
predicted i don't get that either way no
mike i'm with you
well but but here's the thing by the
time they're hiring a general manager
jack easterby will have had 12 weeks of
experience as interim gm
and i i i have a predict i don't i don't
look i don't want to say that it's
definitely going to happen i'm not going
to be surprised if cal mcnair decides to
make jack ease to be the gm by the time
it's all set yeah well
maybe
i i i won't be surprised if they only
win a handful of games over the next few
years if that happens either then you
know that that's to me you'll be a
consensus builder you don't have to have
any experience in scouting you don't
have to have any experience in salary
cap management you don't have to have
any experience in coaching or evaluating
players from other teams or balancing
out proper trades you don't have to have
any of that you can just be a consensus
builder who threads the needle for all
the other people who report to you that
has been sold successfully in the past
and um
yeah
well yeah my words it's it's that's not
that's not what it's gonna get it done i
mean you know uh ozzie newsome and john
schneider and uh
other great gm's around nick you know
nick casario with new england and you
know whoever else i'm missing out there
you know the brandon beans the veaches
uh our guy in in indianapolis uh who i'm
blanking at chris ballard chris ballard
right i mean yeah no they're not
overseers they're like in the nooks and
crannies of evaluating players and
scheme and what this does and wait this
player's good but how good is he is the
scheme helping him all of those things
these are real
football guys so if you're gonna have a
guy that's not a real football guy
making real football decisions
i would say to the mcnair family then
don't expect to win a lot of football
games that's what i would say you know
it's okay to have jack easter be to like
what you're saying be an overseer you
know whatever president of football
operations or whatever title they want
to give him but when you started getting
into a guy who
yes has a limited background of
evaluating players if any background at
all and doing that
uh that's a little scary that's why i
don't understand like why didn't they
just like some one of the higher up
scouts or something like that just
anoint him the gm and have easter bee
watch over that department a little bit
not actually make him the gm
yeah and you know what as i sit here and
think about it
to the extent that that he has
successfully strategized and implemented
and calculated his way to the job that
he now has as executive vp of football
operations we talked earlier in the week
he's got the perfect setup where he's
not accountable for what goes on on the
field he can take credit when things go
well
as he does in his online bio but you run
for cover when things don't go well
and if you're the gm you can't do that
if you're the executive ep of football
operations you got an easier path to
that because ultimately it's others who
are responsible for the on-field product
not you so
but that's all the more reason not to be
there in interim gm don't even put your
hand anywhere close to the fire that's
what makes it even more surprising that
he would aspire to that and uh of course
now he can say on his resume moving
forward he was the general manager of
the houston texans for 12 weeks and
in 2020 and i'm being somewhat facetious
and somewhat not somewhat not facetious
but uh
you know the bottom line is he's going
to emerge from this episode with more
power and the people who get hired
ultimately are going to be answering to
him in one way or another it's almost
like he's a surrogate owner or that
buffer that liaison between gm coach and
owner and he's not going to just
voluntarily give that up
you don't you don't
you don't implement a plan
effectively and successfully to
accumulate power in any organization and
then just hand it over no it's stupid no
you don't do that so uh that's where
that's heading all right um you got
anything else before i got one last
thing i want to say about the texans
yeah no i was just gonna say like yeah i
just i'm gonna be interested to see how
much they've empowered him
and how it affects the next search and
when we get there i mean if you know if
you're a big-time gm or a guy that you
think like whoa we like this guy they
might not like the how this is set up
and that might turn people coaches coach
candidates and gm candidates to where
yeah i wonder how much power he does
have because the next gm might be like
hey if you want me at this gm i don't
know but jack easterby needs to be over
in that room or that building he doesn't
run football or whatever and i just
wonder you know what that'll do
conflicts of interest and where that'll
bring this texan football team
it limits the universe of candidates we
talked about that earlier in the week if
jack easterby has significant power you
are not going to be pursuing general
manager and coaching candidates who
would say
either in the interview or first day on
the job get this guy out of my face yeah
i don't want this guy around here check
out this guy's resume he don't know what
he's talking about let him go do what it
is that he does right character coach
and making making players feel better
and making family members feel better
and talking a very strong game in that
regard and that's fine there's a role
for someone like that but it's not
running the football operation it's not
having oversight of the gm and the coach
and the bottom line is what cal mcnair
wants to do is what's going to happen
but you may not get the best gm and the
best coach
if they have to ultimately answer to
someone that from a football standpoint
they're not going to respect period yeah
it's truth right
jack if you're watching sorry it's the
truth and that's the reality and texans
fans you should be concerned that you're
not going to get the best possible gm
and head coach because of someone who
has accumulated power quickly who is not
going to want to surrender that power
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports